are with the brave people of ukraine
sadly what we have warned against for
months has come to pass
despite
all calls on russia to change course and
tireless efforts to seek
a diplomatic solution
peace on our continent has been
shattered
we now have war in europe on a scale and
of another type
we thought belonged to history
we have just finished a meeting of the
north atlantic council to discuss the
situation
the council also addressed the request
by bulgaria the czech republic estonia
latvia lithuania poland romania
and slovakia to hold urgent
consultations
under article 4 of the washington treaty
this is a grave
moment for the security of europe
russia's unjustified and unprovoked
attack on ukraine's on ukraine is
putting countless innocent lives at risk
with air and missile attacks
ground forces and special forces from
multiple directions
targeting military infrastructure
and major urban centers
this is a deliberate
cold-blooded
and long-planned invasion
despite its litany of lies denials and
disinformation
the kremlin's intentions are clear for
the world to see
russia's leaders bear full
responsibility
for their reckless actions and the lives
lost
nato allies condemn russia's invasion of
ukraine in the strongest possible terms
it is a blatant violation of
international law
an act of aggression
against a sovereign independent and
peaceful country
and a serious threat
to euro-atlantic security
we call on russia to immediately seize
its military action
we draw its forces from ukraine
and choose diplomacy
we fully support ukraine's sovereignty
and territorial integrity
and ukraine's right to self
defense
russia is using force to try to rewrite
history
and deny
ukraine its free and independent path
nato's core task is to protect and
defend all allies
there must be no room for miscalculation
or misunderstanding
an attack on one
will be regarded as an attack on all
this is our collective security
guarantee
today the north atlantic council decided
to activate our defence plans
at request of our top military commander
general todd walters
this is a prudent and defensive step to
protect and shield allied nations during
this crisis
and it will enable us to deploy
capabilities and forces
including the nato response force to
where them are needed
in response to russia's massive military
buildup
we have already strengthened our
collective defense on land at sea and in
the air
in the last weeks
allies from north america and europe
have deployed thousands or more troops
to the eastern part of the alliance
and placed more on standby
we have over
100 jets at high alert
protecting our airspace
and more than 120 allied ships at sea
from the high north to the mediterranean
all this shows that our collective
defense commitment article 5 is ironclad
we will continue to do whatever is
necessary to shield the alliance from
aggression
i have called a virtual summit of nato
leaders tomorrow to address the way
forward
russia is now facing severe costs and
consequences imposed by the whole
international community
the kremlin's aim
is to re-establish
its sphere of influence
rip up the global rules that have kept
us all safe for decades
and subvert the values that we hold
there
this is
the new normal for our security
peace cannot
be taken for granted
freedom and democracy are contested by
authoritarian regimes
and strategic competition is on the rise
we must respond
with renewed resolve
and even stronger unity
north america and europe together in
nato
we are an alliance of 30 democracies
standing as one
we will protect our people and our
values democracy will always prevail
over autocracy
freedom will always prevail over
oppression